this actually makes a lot of sense for a  lot of you are that are of the age you  remember that vine was really the app  that kind of started this short form  silly creative content thing before Vine  it was a Twitter Facebook Instagram  world and Instagram was photos at that  time and Twitter is exactly what it  looks like now and Facebook had  dominance with Facebook fan pages but it  wasn't a Creator economy YouTube had  become long-formed Vines DNA is really  the DNA of what is the modern Social  Network game and so many people have  entertained through this platform  entertainment's about to become more  important because entertainment explodes  as a value during times of tension and  economic struggles if you look at the  Great Depression and other other times  entertainment music film explodes I  think Vine in the Twitter ecosystem is a  viable play